basically what happens in the in the us
is i think that the healthcare system is
for a lot of people no longer
sustainable which means that if they
need the help of the healthcare system
they're often not able to afford it and
when they cannot help it they are often
going bankrupt it's i think the leading
course cause of personal bankruptcy in
the us is the healthcare system
yeah and that would not be necessary
it's not because people are consuming
more and more uh medical services and
are achieving a much much longer life as
a result that's not actually the story
that is happening because you can
compare to other countries and life
expectancy in the us is currently not
increasing and it's not as high as in
all the other industrialized countries
so some industrialized countries are
doing better with a much cheaper
healthcare system
and
what you can see is for instance
administrative bloat the uh
healthcare system has maybe to some
degree deliberately set up as a job
placement program to allow people to
continue living in middle class
existence despite not having a useful
use case in productivity so they are
being paid to push paper around and the
number of administrators in the health
healthcare system has been increasing
much faster than the number of
practitioners and this is something that
you have to pay for right and also the
revenues that are being generated in the
health care system are relatively large
and somebody has to pay for them and
the result why they are so large is
because market mechanisms are not
working right the fda is largely not
protecting people from malpractice of
healthcare providers the fda is
protecting healthcare providers from
competition right okay so this is a
thing that is has to do with values and
this is not because people are malicious
on all levels it's because they are not
incentivized to act on
a greater whole on this idea that you
treat somebody who comes to you as a
patient like you would treat a family
member yeah but yeah but we're trying i
mean
you're highlighting a lot of the flaws
of the different institutions the
systems we're operating under but i
think there's a continuum throughout
history
mechanism design
of trying to design incentives in such a
way that these systems behave better and
better and better i mean it's a very
difficult thing to operate
a society of hundreds of millions of
people effectively with yes so do we
live in a society that is ever
correcting is this uh right do we
observe that our models of uh what we
are doing are predictive of the future
and when they are not we improve them
our laws uh
adjudicated with clauses that you put
into every law what is meant to be
achieved by that law and the law will be
automatically repealed if it's not
achieving that right if you are
optimizing your own laws if you're
writing your own source code you
probably
make an estimate of what is the thing
that's currently wrong in my life what
is it that i should change about my own
policies what is the expected outcome
and if that outcome doesn't manifest
i will change the policy back right or i
will change it to something different
are we doing this on a societal level i
think so i think i think it's easy to
sort of highlight the
i think we're doing it in the way that
um
like i operate my current life i didn't
sleep much last night uh
you would say that uh lex the way you
need to operate your life is you need to
always get sleep the fact you didn't
sleep last night
is is totally the wrong way to operate
in your life like you should have gotten
all your done in time and gotten to
sleep because sleep is very important
for health and you're highlighting look
this person is not sleeping look the the
medical the health care system is
operating poor but the point is that we
just
it seems like this is the way especially
in the capital society we operate we
keep running into trouble and last
minute we we try to get our our way out
through innovation and it seems to work
you have a lot of people that ultimately
are trying to build a better world and
and get
urgency about them
when it's the problem becomes more and
more imminent
and that's the way this operates but if
you look at the
the
the history the the long arc of history
it seems like that
operating on deadlines
produces progress and builds better and
better systems you probably agree with
me that the us should have engaged in
mass production in january 2020
and that we should have shut down the
airports early on and that we should
have uh made it mandatory that the
people that work in nursery homes uh are
living on campus rather than living at
home and then uh coming in and infecting
uh people in the nursing homes that had
no immune response to covet
and
that is something that was i think
visible back then the correct decisions
haven't been made
we would have the same situation again
how do we know that these wrong
decisions are not being made again have
the people that made the decisions to
not protect the nursing homes been
punished
has have the people that made the wrong
decisions with respect to testing that
prevented the development of testing by
startup companies and the importing of
tests from countries that already had
them have these people been held
responsible yeah well first of all so
what do you what do you want to like uh
put before the firing squad i think they
are no just make sure that this doesn't
happen again no but
you see but it's not that yes they're
being held responsible by many voices by
people being frustrated there's new
leaders being born now they're going to
see rise to the top in 10 years
this moves slower than
there's obviously a lot of uh older
incompetence and bureaucracy and these
systems move slowly they move you know
like science one death at a time so like
yes i think the the pain has been felt
in the previous year is reverberating
throughout the world maybe i'm getting
old i suspect that every generation in
the us after the war has lost the plot
even more i don't see this development
the war world war ii yeah so basically
there was a time when uh we were
modernist and in this modernist time
uh the u.s felt actively threatened by
the things that happened in the world
the u.s was worried about possibility of
failure
uh this imminence of possible failure
led to decisions where there was a time
when the government would listen to
physicists about how to do things yeah
and the physicists were actually
concerned about what the government
should be doing so they would be writing
letters to the government and so for
instance the decision for the manhattan
project was something that was driven in
the conversation between physicists and
the government i don't think such a
discussion would take place today i i
disagree i think if the virus was much
deadlier we would see a very different
response i think the virus was not
sufficiently deadly and instead because
it wasn't very deadly what happened is
uh the the current system started to
politicize it the mask this is what i
realized with masks early on they were
not
very quickly became not as a solution
but they became a thing that politicians
used to divide the country so that the
same thing has happened with vaccines
same thing so like nobody's really
people weren't talking about solutions
to this problem because i don't think
the problem was bad enough when you talk
about the world the war i think what i
think our lives are too comfortable
i think in uh in the developed world
things are too good and we have not
faced severe dangers
when the danger the severe dangers
existential threats are faced that's
when we step up on a small scale in a
large scale now i don't
i
that's sort of my argument here but i
did think the virus is
i was hoping that it was actually
sufficiently uh dangerous
for us to step up because especially in
the early days it was unclear it still
is unclear because of mutations
how bad it might be
right and so
i thought we would step up and
even so the masks point is is uh is a
tricky one because
to me the the manufacturer of masks
isn't isn't even the problem i'm still
to this day and i was involved with with
a bunch of this work have not seen good
signs done on whether masks work or not
like there still has not been a large
scale study to me that should be there
should be large scale studies and every
possible solution like aggressive in the
same way that the vaccine development
was aggressive there should be masks
which test what kind of tests work
really well uh what kind of uh like even
the question of how the virus spreads
there should be aggressive studies on
that to understand i'm still
as far as far as i know there's still a
lot of uncertainty about that nobody
wants to see this as an engineering
problem that needs to be solved it's
it's uh
that i was surprised about but i find
that our views are largely convergent
but not completely so i agree with the
thing that
because our society in some sense
perceives itself as too big to fail
right and the virus did not alert people
to the fact that we are facing possible
failure
that basically put us into the
post-modernist mode and i don't mean in
the philosophical sense but in a
societal sense the difference between a
postmodern society and the modern
society is that the modernist society
has to deal with the ground truth and
the postmodernist society has to deal
with appearances
politics becomes a performance
and the performance is done for an
audience and the organized audience is
the media and the media evaluates itself
via other media right so you have an
audience of critics that evaluate
themselves and i don't think it's so
much the failure of the politicians
because to get in power and to stay in
power you need to be able to deal with
the published opinion well i think it
goes into in cycles because the what's
going to happen
is all of the small business owners all
the people who truly are suffering and
will suffer more because the effects
of uh the closure of the economy and the
lack of solutions to the virus they're
going to a prize and hopefully
i mean this is this is where charismatic
leaders can get the
the world in trouble but hopefully we'll
um
elect great leaders
that will break through this
post-modernist idea of
of
the media and the perception and the
drama on twitter and all that kind of
stuff but you know this can go either
way yeah
when the weimar republic was unable to
deal with the economic crisis that
germany was facing
there was an option to go back
and there were people which thought
let's get back to a constitutional
monarchy and let's get this this to work
because democracy doesn't work
and eventually uh there was no way back
people decided there was no way back
they needed to go forward and the only
options for going forward was to become
a stalinist communist basically um
an option to completely expropriate
the factories and so on and nationalize
them and to reorganize
germany and communist terms and ally
itself with stalin
and fascism and both options were
obviously very bad
and the one that the germans picked led
to a catastrophe that was uh that
devastated europe
and i'm not sure if the u.s has an
immune response against that i think
that the
far right is currently very weak in the
u.s but this can easily change
you